كثيرا تواجد اليوم في الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه ولقائي بخامه الرئيس
عبد المجيد تبون وتشرفت بنقل تحيات سيدي
خادم الحرمين الشريفين والسنون العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
لفخامته وللشعب الجزائري الشقيق زياره
اليوم تاتي استكمالا واستمرارا للتعاون
والتنسيق
الوطيد بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجزائر في كافه الامور وفي هذه الزياره
بالذات فيما يتعلق بالشان العربي باعتبار
الجزائر هي رئيسه القمه العربيه الحاليه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ستستلم ان شاء
الله الرئاسه في الفتره القادمه وقد وجدت
كالعاده توافق تام في الرؤى بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والجزائر
وقد استشعرت من فخامه الرئيس حرصه على
المضي قدما في كافه مجالات التعاون بين
بلدينا على الثنائي وهناك فرص كثيره في
هذا الاطار بالذات في تعزيز التبادل
التجاري هناك ارتفاع مضطرد خلال السنوات
الماضيه ونرى فرص لتعزيز هذا
الاستمرار في بحث مجالات التنسيق والتعاون
الاخرى ولا شك ان التعاون والتنسيق على
المستوى الثنائي والمتعدد بين الجزائر
والمملكه يخدم ليس فقط بلدينا لكن امن
واستقرار العالم العربي ومنطقتنا بشكل
الاوسع
والمجتمع الدولي كاملا فسنستمر ان شاء
الله في هذا التعاون والتنسيق وشكرا
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات